よろしくお願いします
今日は第二部で釈尊の真理の世界というテーマでございます
ちょっと難しくなるかもしれませんが
できるだけわかりやすく簡単単純でしゃべることは努力はします
もしその努力を失敗したならば
まあちょっと我慢をしていただいて
真剣に聞いていただきたいんです
ちゃんと聞くと 大体仏教っていうのはわかるもんなんです
そんなに人間にわからないほど難しいことではないんです
あくまでも人間の常識に理性に話しかけているんです
この前も説明しましたから
人間のこの超自然的なこととかね
もう超越したものとかね
そういうものには何も話しかけてないんです
ですから 我々すでに持っている日常的な常識
それに話しかけているんだから
まあちょっとだけ耳を反って聞くならばわかります
ですから あまり難しいと言ったっても
あまり気にする必要はございません
じゃあ 仏教と他の宗教とどういうところで違いますかということはもうすでに説明いたしましたが
その立場から今日から話を進めます
で 大体科学的で結構合理的で
物事を証明しなさいという立場から喋っているんですね
証明もないのに信じるということは人間はしません
例えばまた悪い例なんですけど
私が出すのは悪いだけで
例えばキリスト教ではジェズス様が神様の子で神であると言っているんですね
ですから それを証明しなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ 人一人の人が私は神ですよと言ったっても
いい加減にしなさいと言われればそれで終わりますからね
あるいはあなた病気ではないかと言われたら終わりますから
ですから 聖書にさえジェズス様が神の子であるということは証明するためにいろいろ情報あるんですね
いろんな人の病気治したとか
水の上を歩いたとかね
ちょっとひとかけらのパンと魚１匹持って
もう大勢の人々に食べさせたとかね
そういう話はあって それは一般常識では考えられないもの
一般常識で考えられないものをなさった
なさったんだから やっぱり神様の子だと思う
そうと思うしか方法はないのではないかという論理なんですね
ですから そういう他の宗教にしたっても
そこに見えるのは 人間というのは何か証拠がなければ
まああまり信じようとしないんですね
ですから その立場はもう徹底的に仏教では守っているんですね
であまりああいう風な
この超能力的な話は証拠に出さないんです
そこはまた仏教のちょっとした違うところで
お釈迦様はそういうものは断るんです
この前も言いましたから
超能力的な能力はお釈迦様にもありましたし
お釈迦様の弟子たちにもごく普通に一般的にあったんですね
だから それを出して私が偉いと言ったっても
もう一人の人がまたそういう超能力を持って私も偉いですと言ったら
どちらが偉いか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから そういうものは大体人間に
たまに人間に付くもので
それもあまり証拠にはならないと
ですから まあごく一般的に
どんな人間にも理解できるような立場から
この知識に話しかけて
お釈迦様は説法をなさっているんです
じゃあ お釈迦様の真理の世界になると
我々はちょっと皆様もご存知
一つのストーリー エピソードを考えなくちゃいけないんです
これ どういうエピソードかというと
皆様聞いたことがあると思いますけど
お釈迦様は釈族という釈族で生まれて
王子として生まれたんですね
スッドダナという王様の息子で
一人息子で生まれたんです
で そこで何も問題ない
大変贅沢な生活をしていたんです
でお釈迦様 それはでっち上げた話ではないんです
お釈迦様は自分でも言ってるんです
私はもう想像以上に贅沢していたんだと
日夜自分の頭の上に在家でいた時はみんな傘を差してるんだと
いわゆるまあ 雨が降らなくても
この空気の中に水というかありますね
それは体につきますよ
それぐらいのことからでも体を守ってあげようと
それぐらいの贅沢なんですね
だからいつでも音楽隊がいて
聞きたい時にいつでも演奏できるように
みんなもう準備OKな状態で２４時間なんです
いつ聞きたくなるかわかりません
だから今我々テレビは好きな時にスイッチ入れて見たり
ラジオをつけて聞いたりしますね
それ２４時間体制ですからね
昔はちょっと訳が違いますね
人間がやらなくちゃいけない
それ大変なんですね まあそれぐらいの贅沢をなさっていたんです
で 苦労っていうようなことは全く知らなかったんです
何が苦労かっていうことは全く知らなかったんです
そこで一般的に考えると
宗教に走る人々っていうのは何か問題あるんですよ
一般的にはね 会社がうまくいかないとか
もうなんか問題 もう子供が不良に走ったとかね
そうするとお母さんが宗教に走っちゃうし
どっちでも不良になってしまっちゃいますけど
で そういう何か問題があると宗教に走る
インドでも同じなんです
皆様も我々日本人だけというふうに何か落ち込む必要ないんです
お釈迦様の時代でもインドでも同じなんです
例えば自分が大財産を持っていて
この財産全部なくなったと
もう食べる道が消えちゃったと
それでもうしょうがないんですね
出家でもしようと思って出家生活しちゃうとか
あるいはもう治らない病気になっちゃって
もう在家で生活できないんですね
だから在家でいるのはうちの人々にとって迷惑なんですね
そういうことで出家するとか
あるいはもうもう生活して
子供が大きくなって もう家でやることがなくなっちゃうんですね
インドでは大体子供が大きくなっちゃうと
子供に財産を任すという習慣が昔あったんです
全部任せちゃう 親は引退する
引退するのはいいんだけど
それからやることないんですね
それで日本と違ってずっとお嫁さんにいじめてやろうということはないんです
やることなくなっちゃう
じゃあお嫁さんいじめてやろうと
一生そういうことは全くないんですね
ですから その代わりにやることないとつまらないし
じゃあ出家しようと 出家して
もう家のことは全く関係なく自由な人間になって
最後にでも人間が自由にならなくちゃいけないんだと
皆様方は自由じゃないんです
家に束縛されて 会社に束縛されて
もうそんな好き勝手に生活できないんですね
でも人間の心っていうのは自由になりたいと
という気持ちがあるんですね
ですから インドでは年取ってから出家すると
もう年取ってからでも自由になってやりましょうということであります
社会問題にもなってますけどね
まあたまにこの怠け者男たちが家族あるのに
子供たちいるのに平気で好き勝手に
現代インドではね まああっちこっち
まあ何て言います 巡礼に行っちゃうんですね
1年  2年  3年  5年とかね
インドはちょっと大きい国だからね
まあ 1週間でもできませんね
まあ帰ってくるのは ですからまあそんなこともやりますけど
それはまあ僕から見れば
まあなんかすごいいけないことだと感じますけど
出家するよりは子供の面倒見た方がもっと人間らしくて正しいと思います
それは個人の意見で インド人はそうは思ってないみたいし
とにかくお釈迦様の時代でも出家したのは何か問題あるとということになっちゃうんですね
そこで私は悪口を言うのは大変有名だから
私は私の言葉にそれ解釈すると
この腰抜けと間抜けとか
あるいはもう失敗 人生失敗している人々が出家すると
宗教に走ると ですから
出家 宗教のグループというのは
みんなこの負け犬同士の集まりになっちゃうんです
社会で負けて負け犬同士が集めて
まあなんとか我々お互いに助け合って何かやろうではないかと
それは事実なんです 遠いインドでも今
の社会でもね 例えば皆様でも皆様どうか分かりませんんだけど
大体一般的にはもう仕事も万事うまくいってるんだと
家族はもう平和で もう円満で
何も問題ないんだと まあ子供たちはしっかりと
旦那さんがしっかりとしているんだと思っちゃったら
もうそれでもう満足して
もう外へ出ようともしないんです
で そこで何か問題あっちゃったら
あっちこっち まあいろんな精神的な世界やら神秘的なところやら
いろいろご利益何かどこかで貰えませんかと
まあご利益ちょうだいちょうだいと言って走り回っちゃうんですね
ですから 現代の日本という社会にしたっても
まあ何かすごい知恵を求めて
何か真理を求めて より高度な生き方を求めていくという人はもうまずないと言ったっても構いません
そこをまず我々は正直に認めましょう
別にまあごまかしする必要ないんだから
で そこで問題になるのは
じゃあ釈迦尊にどんな問題があったんですかと
どこら辺で負けたんですかと
何ができなかったんですか
そこで仏教経典では徹底的に書くんですね
お釈迦様にはできなかったものは何もなかったんだと
そこで生まれつきすごい天才でしたから
どんなものでも聞いただけで覚えるんです
ですから 膨大なインドの知識っていうのはあっという間に勉強してしまっちゃったんです
すごい能力あったんです
そこでものすごい健康的な体で
それまたものすごい美男で
それ何一つも欠けることなかったんです
で そこで別に強引に言ってるわけじゃなくて
この釈迦族っていうのは
このネパール地方の人々で
結構立派な美しい体 今でもまあ立派な体の人々はいっぱいいるんです
南インドみたいな 僕みたいな醜い体格ではないんです
ですから このすごい美しく光り輝いている体で
もうしっかりした王子で生まれて
まあ体力もあって その上もう頭もすごいことで何も問題なかったんですね
それで王子だから もう何か困るということは何もなかったんですね
そこでご飯食べる時はどれぐらい贅沢したんですかというと
この家来の人々が米一粒一粒数えてみて
壊れていない完璧な米を選んで
このお釈迦様のご飯炊いてあげたんだと
その時お釈迦様と言わないんだけど
このシッダールタ王子ですね
それぐらい贅沢していたんです
それで家出しましたからね
なんでしょうかね あれは
私たち普通常識の人だったらね
あれに酔って絶対もう世の中夜中見ようとしないんですね
そこは仏教の違うところなんですね
この空いてるもので あ
そうかそうかと じゃあ分かったと
そんなもう言う通りに尻尾巻いてはい分かりましたって
そんな状態じゃないんです
世の中っていうのは嘘ばっかりなんですね
なんか宣伝 いろいろコマーシャルありますね
みんな嘘ばっかり言ってるんですね
美しい人を出したりして
品物を売ろうとして 人は可愛いかもしれません
人気あるかもしれません
だからって言って売ってるものはだからいいわけじゃないでしょうに
でも我々はテレビコマーシャルや宣伝見る人々はすぐそれでもつい買ってしまっちゃうと
何かどこかで猿みたい犬みたいなところあるんです
言われたらすぐやってしまっちゃうと
例えばあの人すごいなと言ったら
みんなそうですか すぐ決めてしまっちゃうんですね
で 本読む時でも その人はどんな肩書き持ってるんですか？とか
間違ってでもアメリカの大学でも卒業しているならば
東大卒業でもあるならば
もう必ずその本は信頼して読んでしまっちゃうとかね
そういう我々にはちょっとした問題はあるんです
釈迦尊にはそれはないんです
なかったんです 人間がなんかごまかしやってるんではないかと
で よくやはり余裕があるんだから
それ屈になっちゃったんですね
勉強するものはなし どんな立派な先生方が来て
じゃあこれから勉強しようと
これは年かかりますよと言って始めたら
もう全部もう一日二日間で終わっちゃうんですね
そうするともう時間が有り余っちゃって
やることなくなっちゃうんですね
皆様も知ってるでしょうと思いますけど
この天才みたいな子供たち生まれるでしょ
かなり精神的な問題に引っかかっちゃうんです
で 日本だったらもう潰せますから問題ないんだけど
このアメリカだったらもう能力持っていたらとものすごくもう応援しちゃうでしょ
ですから 歳になったっても大学に入れるんですね
歳っていうのはもうちっちゃな子供だからね
もうおもちゃで遊んだりとか
いろいろことやったりして
でも頭いいんだから もう大学に入って勉強したりして
もうもう歳になってもう博士もらってるんです
で それでこのどんな大人見たっても
どんな偉大なる教授見たっても
自分と同じレベルだからね
なんかすごく屈辱を感じちゃうみたいんです
それで親にしても どうすることもできないんですね
子供は抜群の能力を持っていて
一人前で で また体洗ってあげたりとか
あんたご飯食べてしっかりご飯食べなさいとかね
ちゃんとネクタイをちゃんと締めなさいとかね
そういういちいち面倒見ることできなくなっちゃうんですね
もうしっかりしているんだから
天才だから で そこでもう天才でありがたいと我々思うんだけど
そこら辺にものすごいまた落とし穴があるんですね
我々は天才でなくてばかり生まれてよかったのは
まあいちいちあなたあれをやったんですかと思い出してくれないと忘れちゃう
また忘れちゃうし ですから
みんなに仕事があるんですね
親にも仕事があるんですね
子供は宿題して 宿題はそっちに置いておいて
学校に行くんですね そこでお母さんが走っていって
まああんたもうこれ宿題宿題持っていけないんですかとかね
あなたの弁当はどうしますかとかね
ですから 一応うまくいってるんです
子供の頭の悪さも親は補ってあげる
親にもそれなりの仕事があるし
それでお互いにもう助け合って
どんどんどんどん自然的に成長しますよ
天才になっちゃったらもうそんな話じゃないんです
子供と遊ぶことさえできなくなっちゃうんですよ
我々のこんな頭で天才みたいな子供と全然喋れないんだから
ですから やっぱり大人の立場なくなっちゃうんですね
それはそれで そういう落とし穴もあるんです
それで 釈尊も同じひどい目にあった人なんです
そういう並の天才ではなかったんだから
ですから 王様が 自分の父親が占いで聞いていたんですね
この人はとどまりませんと
一箇所には で 占ってみたら
ものすごい天才で 人類の 1年一番目の人になるんだと
どこへ行っても サイケデいたっても出家したっても
もうこれは止まることはできませんと
ですから どうせうちには止まりっこはないんだと
そこで親の親バカだから
この子には一生懸命もう苦労はさせないで
もう最高の贅沢してあげましょうということで
ああいうふうに贅沢してあげたんですね
小さい時ももう宮殿を 3つ作ってくれて
そこでその時期季節変わるたびにもう一つから一つに大移動して生活して
その中からお釈迦様はやっぱり考えたんですね
これは全部見せ物だと
この中に何かあるはずですよと
何かごまかしするんではないかと
考えたんです で どうせ知識ある人にわかるでしょうに
例えば自分の召使いたちが
家来たちが 24時間体制で交代で自分の面倒を見ると
自分がただもう何かあれこれというだけで
じゃあ踊りなさいというだけで
頭がいいんだから で 踊る側の立場から考えちゃうと違う世界を見えちゃうんですね
人の大変な苦しみの上で自分が贅沢しているのではないかと
これは人間の生きるべき道じゃないんだと
これは人間の歩む道じゃないんだと
ですから 今は我々はこの民主主義の世界で
自由な社会で 誰も誰をもう支配支配しようとは思わないし
まあ支配したいと思ってるんだけど
なかなかできないしね
できればやりますけど
みんな独善的に押さえて支配したい気持ちはあるだけで
もうなかなかできないし
まあ旦那さんにも自分の奥さんを支配したい
奥さんも旦那さんには支配されませんし
それは現代社会でそういう状態なんですけど
ですから昔はそれ違ったんだからね
でお釈迦様その当時でそれを発見したんですね
これはある一人の人がもう王政の人を支配して抑えて
自分一人だけ贅沢して
それで幸福かと それは幸福ですかと
もう一つ ものすごい責任を持っていた人なんですね
それで王子として育てられたでしょ
あなたは王様で 国民を守らなくちゃいけない
国民の面倒を見なくちゃいけないという育ち方だから
こんな食べては寝る 寝ては食べる
遊ぶ 遊ぶは食べるは寝るは
そんなことをやって国民の面倒見られますかね
ですから 現代政治家と違って自分さえ良ければいいということはなかったんですね
やっぱり本物の王子になりたならば
なりたければ やっぱり人間の苦しみを何とかしなくちゃいけない
で そこでまたいろいろ考えたところで
なんかちょっと違う道に走るようになっちゃったんです
そこで考えたところで
こういう問題があったんですね
一つは自分で不幸を感じた
それですごくいいポイントなんで
覚えておいてください
皆様方は贅沢したいでしょ
本当は お金がいっぱいあって
仕事はうまくいって もう何でも万事うまくいって
もう幸福になりたいでしょ
なってみてください えらいつまらなくなるんです
で 私は奥様たちの話を聞いたことがありますけど
もうやることはなくて
もうすっごいもうつまらないんだと
もう嫌で嫌でしょうがないんだと
ということは 頭はいいでしょ
みんな女性の方々はもう大学に入って勉強したりするし
男よりは真面目に勉強するし
ですからまあどうせ頭はいい
それでまあ今便利な社会だからね
もう何のことなく 家のお仕事なんかはもうさっさと終わってしまっちゃうし
残りの時間何するんですかね
子供のオムツ替えるだけでね
すごい知識を持って 子供は小さい時はそれで忙しいんだからね
自分の苦しみに気が付かないんだけど
子供は中学生 小学生になってくると大変なんでやることは全くないんだから
子供嫌ですからね 自分の体触ったりいろいろやったりするのは
その時はやることなくなっちゃうんですね
だからもう本当に不幸なんですね
頭も良くて で 頭の何の勉強をしたことがなかったならば
私にはこの家のお仕事することは何もできませんよと思って
そこで納得いきますけどね
でも納得いかないんですね
すごく頭がいいんだから
勉強して知識があるんだから
ですから やっぱり幸福になっちゃうと
そこにドーンと現れるのは不幸なんですね
すごい苦しみなんですね
誰でも堕落しちゃうんです
これはもう男性であろうが女性だろうが関係ないんです
ですから もうやたらに幸福になります
幸福になりますとかね
すごい金持ちになって贅沢しなくちゃいけませんとかね
そんなことは遊びでいいんだけど
実際になってみたら まあひどい目に遭うもんなんです
ですからまあもうまあまあの状態で文句をいくらか言いながら生きることこそが一番いいんです
例えば万円は欲しいんだけど
万円しかない もっと万円あればいいなという状態はいいんです
万円が欲しいところで
万しか持ってないと苦しいんです
お金ないんだから 万円欲しいところで万なっちゃったらもう不幸になっちゃうんです
全然面白くないんです
その場合は考えてみてください
さっと行って物を買ったと
面白くないんです そこで本当に買いたいものがあるんだけど
万円足らない そこでもう旦那さんにもいろいろ話をつけたりして
また自分のお母さんにいるなお母さんにもなんとか言ったりとか
あるいは友達からちょっともう借りてもらったりとか
買ったところで ああ もう楽しいんです
そこで分割でお金を払うとかね
本当の人生の楽しみはそういうものなんです
でも人間っていうのは不思議なことに
それを嫌だと思っちゃうんですね
使いたい放題お金あれば楽しいんだと
男の人々の生活を見てください
使いたい放題お金入っちゃったらどうするんですかと
自分の人生は全部台無しにしてもう終わってしまっちゃうんですね
最終的にはホームレスで終わっちゃうんです
そういうもんなんです
人生っていうのは ですから
今私が言うのもお釈迦様の知恵なんです
お釈迦様は年の前で あの贅沢をした時代で
それを最終的に発見したんですね
これはすごい罠だと 何の成長もないんだと
そこで人間の苦しみをなくそうと思って
例えば王子にな王になって救済活動すると
それ考えたら 救済活動して人に幸福幸福にしてあげたと人が人を幸福にしてあげたという形跡は歴史の中でないんです
実際に 今日本は経済成長して
経済的にもう世界で一流の国でしょ？じゃあみんなお金に対して何の問題もないんですか？日本の政府というのは膨大な借金しているんだから
なんで借金したか分かりませんだけどね
一人当たり何百万円ですかね
すごい借金で皆様も財布もいろいろもう苦しいし
いっそこれは良くなるかと
昨日私にある人を聞いたんだけどね
はっきり僕は答えたかったんだけど
これは絶対ならないんだと
良くはこれからもと まあこれから経済
日本の経済状態はどうなるんですか？よくなりますかと僕に聞いたんで
僕はいろいろごまかしちゃったんだけど
正しい答えは良くなりませんと
そのままですと 良くならないんです
で それいくら経済活動したっても
いつでもどこかに問題あるんです
完璧な状態になるということはないんです
経済っていうのは このエネルギーと同じく
この高いところから低いところに流れると
だからアンバランスでなければ経済というのは流れないんですよ
日本では車作っちゃうんだと
外国の人はそんなもの要りませんよと思っちゃったら全部ゴミだけでしょうに
向こうはもう頭が悪くて車欲しい車欲しいと思ってるんだから
その頭の悪さがこちらで買ってもう車を売って金儲けてるんです
これ言葉は悪いかもしれませんだけど
別にそういうことなんです
それでなんで日本の方々は外国のアメリカのものとかフランスのものとか買ったりするんですかというと
あれ頭の悪いんだから
チャンネルとかなんとかとか名前があったらカッコいいやと思うぐらいの知識だから
フランスやらイタリアやら儲かってるんです
そんなものはどうでもいい
着られればいいんだと
バッグであれなれば何でもいいよと思っちゃったら売れないでしょ
経済っていうのはそういう風にこの弱い者いじめなんです
だから僕に聞いたらね
どうやって自分の会社であろうか
社会であろうか 経済的に豊かになりますかと言えば
僕に仏教徒として答えられますか？思い存分弱い者をいじめなさいということだから
あるいは弱い者がなければ強引に作りなさいと
タレントさんそうでしょう
新しいファッションやら新しいいろんなものを強引に作っちゃって
それで不安を作っちゃって
それで自分が金儲けて食べてるんですね
人を騙して 若者をね みんな追っかけて行っちゃうし
かっこいいかっこいいとか言いながら
だからそこもやっぱり子供たちが心が弱いんだから
そこをつかまってもういじめるんです
弱い者をいじめるということで経済というのは成り立ってるんです
ですから その当時 お釈迦様はこの経済活動で活動は人間の問題の答えではありませんと
他の何かにあるはずですよというところに行っちゃうんですね
それを象徴しているのは
ある皆様も知っている言葉があります
一応パーリ語で書きます
まず  [書き込む]これ
ジャーティ・ジャラ・マラナというんです
ジャーティは生 生まれること
ジャラは老いること マラナは死ぬこと
生老死ですね 日本では生老病死と４つに分けて考えてますけどね
まあそれ入れてあっても構いません
日本語で生老病死と言うんだから
病のパーリ語はジャーティ・ジャラ・ビャーディ
ジャーティ・ジャラ・ビャーディ・マラナ
でもパーリ語はちょっとすごい厳密ですから
その使う場合によって言葉引いたり増えたりするんです
ですから 今の説明では
私はジャーティ・ジャラ・マラナっていうものを使うのは
これを拠点によらなくちゃいけないんだけど
日本語ではみんな簡単に生老病死
生老病死と言うんだけどね
どこでも簡単に生老病死使えるわけでもないんです
とにかくお釈迦様はそこを問題にしたんですね
いわゆる哲学者みたいで
ちょっとまあお腹がいっぱいにしてあげただけで
人間の問題は終わらないんだと
それみんな自分でわかってるでしょう
食べただけで満足しますかね
じゃあ服着るだけで食べて服も着られるんだと
そこで満足しますかね
じゃあマイホームあったらそれだけで満足しますかね
しないんです またどこかに問題が生まれる
一つ解決すると新しい問題が生まれる
そこで問題が新しく生まれたんだから
解決法はわからないんですね
ですから 僕のあの いい加減な言葉で言うならば
慣れてる問題だけで十分じゃないかと
その慣れてる問題解決したらもう慣れてない新しい問題が生まれちゃいますからね
例えばマイホームがないんだと
もう賃貸で賃貸というんですか
そういうところで住んでるんだと
そこでマイホームあってほしいと思っちゃうんですね
当たり前なんですけど
僕はそれでもそのまま言いなさいとと言いたいところなんです
なぜならば 頑張ってマイホーム作っちゃったら
いまだなかった新しい問題出てくるんです
今あるのはうちが自分の家があればいいな
自分の家があればいいなという気持ちだけですね
そこでどうやって借金払いますかとか
もう自分買ったうちだから
これいい加減に使ってはいけませんし
もうあっちこっち引っ越しもできませんし
丁寧にうちを扱わなくちゃいけないし
そこでまあ大変なんですね
であっちこっちからまたお金絞らなくちゃいけないし
あっちこっちからお金の出るところはカットしなくちゃいけないし
それぐらい苦労するようになるならば
まあマンションでよかったのにと
まあどっちにせいても構いませんだけど
まあ問題同じですからね
一つの問題解決すると新しい問題が生まれてくる
そこでちゃんと追求吸収ですか
収拾していっちゃうと
もう人間には基本的にあるのは
この生と老と死の問題
生老病死の問題なんですね
で 例えばわかりやすく言えば
ここで子供が生まれちゃうでしょ
子供が生まれておめでとうございますというのはバカバカらしくて
生まれた瞬間からとんでもないすごい問題いっぱいそこに生まれてるんです
一人の国民が生まれたんだから
じゃあ自分を産んだ子供をちょっといじっていじめてみてください
警察に捕まりますよ まあ日本わかりませんだけど
ヨーロッパだったら子供は国が奪うんです
あなたには親の権利がないんだと
だから自分で産んだ子供ですけど
自分がその瞬間で奴隷になっちゃうんですね
それだけでは まあそれは別に苦痛じゃないんだけど
子供のために仕事をするのは
でも その人が生まれた人が
これからどれほどのことをしなくちゃいけないんですかね
勉強しなくちゃいけないし
歩き方なんもなきゃいけないし
ああだこうだと言葉習わなくちゃいけないし
行儀習わなくちゃいけないし
学校に行かなくちゃいけないし
で 大きくなったら仕事していかないといけないし
結婚しなくちゃいけないし
社会人にならなくちゃいけないし
会社かかってきたら会社を回らなくちゃいけないし
ああだこうだと だからただ生まれることはおめでとうございますのところじゃないんです
例えば我々 今年取っていっちゃうでしょ
で 大変でしょうね 年取るっていうことは
で 年取ると まあどうせ年取るんだからといって放っておくことはできますかね
膝が痛いし 腰が痛いし
もうもう腎臓肝臓があまり活動してくれないし
そこでも毎日ような感じで病院に行ったりとかね
そういうありとあらゆる問題は生と一緒に生まれてくるんです
あれ どこらへんがおめでとうか分からないんですよ
よく見ると 赤ちゃんが生まれておめでとうございますと
どこらへんがおめでとうですかね
大変でしょうに 夜寝られないでしょ
1 年間はね 僕は大学でいた時はある
若い教授が結婚して子供が生まれて
で 彼がこう言うんですね
我々を集めて何か喋っていると
随分疲れてる顔をしてるんです
もうすごい若くて元気で
普通だったらすごい元気で授業とかやっていたんだけどね
最近その時見たら随分疲れてるんです
もう授業なんかもうやる元気もないんですね
で こう言うんですね 自分の奥さんに子供が生まれたんだと
で 生まれたばっかしで
必ず夜起きて泣くんだと
だから奥さんも大変だから
この人もやっぱりその夜起きて
子供をまた寝かせたりとか
交代でやってるんですね
で どうしたってもこれは男性は仕事に行かなくちゃいけないで
仕事は昼もやるものだから
奥さんは子供と一緒に昼寝でもしちゃえば
まあそれなんとかなりますけど
男の場合はまた違うんですね
ですからまあ大変なんですね
とにかく そこでおめでとうございますというのは常識なんですけど
具体的に哲学的に見れば大変でございますねと言った方が正しいんですね
でも真理は語らない 世の中というのは嘘ばっかり語りますからね
例えば子供が生まれたところでね
まあ赤ちゃんが生まれたことは大変でございますというふうに何か手紙出しちゃったら
お礼を出しちゃったら怒られるでしょうね
常識は知りません でもそれは常識なんです
真理なんです ですから
生まれることから全ての問題は我々に現れてくるんです
幸福が待ってるわけじゃないんです
何も用意していないんです
この世の中で 天皇陛下なんかどうかなる場合は
みんな国民が全部用意して
まあ警備やら何から何までそんな状態じゃないんです
人間にとっては 全部もうそこから自分で用意して作ってあげなく作り上げなくちゃいけない
それしたっても 結局は毎日年取っていっちゃう
例えば金持ちになろうと
貧しいんだと 苦しいんだと思って金持ちになると
金持ちになるとどうなってますか？その人が
年取ってるんです もうお金があってもなくてもどうでもいい状態になってるんです
マイホーム作る時でも
もうどうでもいい状態になってるんです
まあ子供のためにとか作っちゃいますけど
もう子供が大きくなって
もう家を出て帰っちゃうんですね
ですから もうなくてもいい時なんですね
入ってくるの ですから
年取ることは問題で それで死ぬということ
全部パーになって無駄になって死んでしまっちゃうんですね
今までやったことは全部無意味で
勉強したことはこの博士とかなんとかなったりとかするでしょ
あれは全部もうゴミ箱
死ぬ時は何の意味もないんですね
命かけて勉強したり 財産を儲けたり
家族を作ったりとかしたのに
全部それ もう死んでしまっちゃうんです
悔しいでしょう 悔しいじゃないんですけど
僕から見ればなんで悔しがらないかと
ですから 人間にとっては本当にそういう４つの問題がありまして
そこで我々 この４つの中で
この生を生まれることは一応置いておいたっても
自分で実感がないんだから
ちょっと思い出せればね
小さい時はすごくきつかったと分かりますよ
皆様にも瞑想実践でもしてみれば結構落ち着きます
落ち着くと過去を思い出せるんです
何のことなく感情あると思い出せませんだけどね
思い出しちゃうと思い出せるならば
自分の小さい時を思い出してみてください
楽しかったかどうか ものすごい大変でしたと思いますよ
今の子供たちも 例えば小学校に初めて行くでしょ
ものすごい神経質になっちゃって
ビクビクして大人と全く同じなんです
会社倒産ギリギリの状態の大人とより精神的にものすごい苦しみを感じているんです
不安で不安でもうたまらないんです
親はこうやって子供を育てるんだから
これついでに言いますけど
この昨日か 電車で僕は外国人のヨーロッパ人の人が自分の子供を抱いて
男の人がね 抱いているのを見たんです
電車で その人は子供をあの背中を自分の方に置いて
顔が向こうに出して こうやって抱いてるんですね
お父さんでしょうですね
抱いて こうやって抱いて
子供は前見て座ってるんですね
手の上に で 電車の中に歩いてきたんですけどね
僕はその瞬間で感じたのは
じゃあお母さんたちだったら
あるいは日本の僕 よく見るのは日本の方々だから
日本のお母様だったらどうしますか？というと
自分の方に子供を向かせて抱いてるんですね
社会に見せてないんですね
あれ見た瞬間で あれって僕の頭に浮かんだのは
あの抱き方は正しいんだと
子供に世界を見せて 自分が守ってあげると
ちっちゃいんだから 自分がお父さんとして守ってあげる
でも世界をそのドーンと堂々と見なさいと
あの子はそれだったら立派な人に育てるだなと思ったんで
あれ見て あれはまあヨーロッパ的なやり方かもしれません
たまにやっぱりその抱き方はある面では正しいかもしれません
なぜならば お母さんの胸に見て抱っこしたらお母さんの胸しか見えませんし
お母さんの体の温かみとかね
それでずっと落ち着いて納得して
あまりも居心地が良くて
その中にいたかっちゃうんですね
でもいられないでずっと大きくなっちゃいますから
そうすると神経質になっちゃうんです
お母さん離れる時は 赤ちゃんの時も社会を見せて抱っこしちゃったらもうずっと他のおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたち見ているんだから
もう怖いもの何にもなくなっちゃうだろうと
私は勝手に妄想しましたけどもね
どうなるかわかりませんだけど
ですから この小さな時
我々でも思い出してみるならば
この小学校に入ることさえすごい大変なことなんです
ものすごいストレスかかっちゃって
緊張神経質になって不安でおしっこも垂らしちゃいますから
だから思い出してみてください
私はもう覚えてますよ
初めて学校に行った日は
あれほど怖い経験はなかったんです
ものすごく怖かったんです
自分が今までいた世界は全部消えちゃって
全く知らない世界に入るんだから
知る人は一人もいないんです
そこで悪いことに 親もお父さんも一緒に来なかったんですね
まあ姉さんがお姉さんがいたんだから
もう年上で結構で任せちゃったんで
連れてきなさいと で そこでまあ自分の姉のスカートにかぶせてなんか守ると思ったって
もう学校に行くまではよかったんです
なんかちゃんともう落ち着かせてくれて
もう大丈夫だとね いろいろ言いながらもう手を引っ張って連れて行って
自分の教室に座らせて
自分も学校に行かなくちゃいけないんだから
もう行っちゃったんですね
もう誰もいないんです
ですから大変なんですよ
子供たちにしても 生きるということは
そんな甘い世界じゃないんです
ですから それはもうとことん体験させなくちゃいけないんだけど
守ってあげてはいけないんだけどね
私は先生守ってくれなかったんだから
その瞬間でつらいんです
僕のやり方は 僕は考えたら
どうせ男は子供っていうのは女の人に慣れてるんだから
周りを見てもう最初の先生は女の先生でしたから
じゃあこの人の気に入るようにしちゃったら
もう自分のことを面倒見てくれるだろうと思って
その時からもう先生の気に入るようにいろいろ工夫しちゃうんですね
なぜかというと このボタン外れたりとかね
スゴン落っこちちゃったりするんです
自分でできないんでそれは
家だとやってくれるでしょ
そうするともうこれ外れちゃったらすごい恥ずかしがっちゃうし
それでなんとかすごくうまく工夫して先生に全部やってもらうということを
まあ本当に先生でもやってくれるとすごくありがたを感じちゃうんですね
それで落ち着くし 落ち着いた経験覚えがあるんですね
まあそんなもんなんです
そこで中学校に行くとか
またショックで高校に行くとまたショックで大学に入ると入ると大ショックなんです
大人なのに向こうは１週間ぐらいいじめられるんですよ
新入生っていうのは あれは形式的ないじめでもどうしても避けられないんです
別に日本みたいに慣れてないんだから悪いことしますけど
向こうはもう伝統的なものだから
イギリスのあれあれでも真似で別に悪いことするわけじゃないんだけど
大恥かけちゃうんですね
例えばみんなちゃんと靴を履いて
もうネクタイでも締めてきちゃったら
ネクタイは首にかけちゃう
靴を紐で結んでもらって首にかけちゃうんです
これかけなさいと お前は何者かと思ってるんですかと
こんな尊いところに来て靴履いていいって
そういうふうに言うんです
口で 脱ぎなさいと だから脱ぐんです
ただそれをもう首にかけなさいと
で ノートなんか頭の上にのせちゃうんです
のせたいと もう準備させちゃうんですね
そのいじめは 1週間は続くんです
1週間終わったらもう何のことないんだけどね
それからお互いにものすごく顔を知ってますよ
先輩たちの それから本当に親切に何だかんだ面倒見てくれるんです
あの 1週間の苦行はしなくちゃいけないんです
で 大人はね あんなことをさせたら
そこで大学の中でやれちゃったら
まだ足らないと思っちゃったら
道路に連れて行っちゃうんです
普通のバス停とかあっちこっちもう歩かせ歩かせちゃうんですね
そういうことまでやっちゃいますから
ですから 僕ら僕らの経験で言えば
大学に入ることはどれほど精神的にきついというと
で そういうものを乗り越えて乗り越えて
まあ人間になりますけどね
ですから まあ人生っていうのはそんなもんで
もう大変なんです だから楽をしようと思ったら
それは大間違いなんです
楽をしようとしない方がいいんですよ
きついんだと思った方がいくらかはもう我慢できるんです
楽をしようと思ったら
もうどうなるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
そこで この場合は 僕はこの生まれることは置いておいて
すぐに出てくるのは年取ることなんですね
年取ることはどれほど嫌かと
例なんですね それで我々みたいな年になってくると
体が病気になるわ 顔は色が悪くなるわ
もう醜くなっていくわ
いろいろ問題なんですね
でもそれはよく考えてください
人間嫌なんです 年取るのは好きということはないんです
我々大人が子供が大きくなるのを楽しみに待ってますけど
その子供にとってみれば
毎日とんでもないひどい目に遭うことだから
大きくなるたびに 我々から見れば
我々年取ることによって
どんどん新しい苦しみが待ってるんです
全然いいものは 何て言いますか
何かプレゼントやらご褒美もらって持って誰が待ってるわけじゃないんです
年取る過程ではご褒美じゃない
すごい苦しみを持ってもう人生は待ってるんです
年取れば取るほど 大体今皆様毎日チェックしてるだろうと思いますけど
三十五 四十になってくると細胞がいつおかしくなるかわからないんですね
いつ自分の細胞はがんになるかとか
だからもう心配するならば心配でも生きていられないほどなんですね
あまりにも心配だから
僕は医者には体は見せない
なぜなら もしがんですよって言ったら
その人言うことを聞かなくちゃいけないでしょ
ですから まあまあいいですと
そんなことはがんでも知らないうちにパッと死んだらそれでいいという感じで
まあまあ それは余計な話なんですけど
まあとにかく我々年取ってる過程で待ってるのは苦しみなんです
それから精神的にいうと
それは嫌なんです 年取ることは嫌ですと
そこに病気になることは好きな人はいますか？いません
それも嫌です 死ぬことはそれも嫌なんですね
わからないだけで 本当は生まれることも嫌なんです
今は忘れてるだけで おなかの中にいた方が一番楽でしたけど
追い出されちゃうんです
おなかの中から 自分居心地よくいるところから追い出されると
誰がいい気持ちになるんですか？ものすごく自分ものすごく居心地が良くて
犬猫でも気持ちよく座っているところから追い出してみてください
ものすごい嫌な気持ちがするんです
だから 野生の動物の場合
その動物の縄張りの中に入ったり
何とかしたりするとすごい嫌な顔するんですね
大きな猛獣みたいな動物だったらもう襲うでしょうに来るなと
そこで我々は最高のいいところにいたところから追い出されると
生まれる瞬間もものすごい嫌な気持ちで
なんか家賃払ってないんだから
家から追い出されるような感じで
全部荷物も外へ出しちゃって出て行けと
惨めな思いなんですよ
もう忘れただけなんです
でも嫌ですけど それは避けられない事実なんです
それに出会わなくちゃいけないんです
生まれなくちゃいけないんです
年取らなくちゃいけないんです
病気にならなくちゃいけないんです
死ななくちゃいけないんです
そこだけ人間の永遠の問題だと
ですから お腹いっぱい食わしてあげることは問題じゃないんだと
問題にならないんだよ
お釈迦様から見れば そこら辺は勉強しなくちゃいけないということで
そこに何か解決法を見つかったら
私は人の助けになったことになりますよと
ただ 王子でいたっても人を助けたことにならない
自分の仕事をしたことにはならない
だから その日で生まれた子供の息子が生まれたんだけど
最高のおくさんもいたんだけど
全部捨てて家出しましたし
で たまに聞こえる聞こえるんだ
お釈迦様は大変悪いことをしたんではないかと
子供が生まれたのに 奥さんも子供も捨てて出家してそれでいいんですかと
それは人間のおかしい考え方で
自分の奥さんと子供の面倒をちゃんと見てあげる男がいるんですかね
僕はかえって聞きたいんですね
いますか？誰一人いませんよ
みんなそれなりに大きくなるだけであって
男は自分にできるだけのことやってるだけなんですよ
何もすることはできませんしね
そこで例えば奥さんに食べられない
旦那さんがお金持ってこなきゃ食べられないと
それらの家出したら それはけしからんの生き方なんですよ
それは良くない お釈迦様の場合
そういうケースじゃないんだから
全部みんな面倒見てるでしょうに
生まれた子供もまた王様の家族で生まれたんだから
おっぱいあげる人はいる
体洗ってあげる人がいる
お父さんとして何もしてあげることないんです
遊んであげる人はいるし
だからかえってつまらないといえばつまらないし
自分でオムツ替えたり
泣いてる時は慰めてあげたりとかね
夜怖くなっちゃったら一緒に寝かしてあげたりとかね
そういうことを何もしなくても済むんだから
王族の人が面倒見てるんだから
ですから別に釈迦さんが家出しましたからといって
家族を置いておいて行ったわけじゃないんです
ですから その二人が大丈夫だと
それは心配する必要は全くないんだと
私はただここで待って座って食べて遊んで食べて遊んで何やってるんですかと
自分も仕事をしなくちゃいけない
それだったら全ての人類の問題解決しますということで出家したんです
ですから お釈迦様の出家の課題は生老病死なんですね
その点で他の宗教とは似ているんです
この宗教の話を聞くと
みんな約束してくれるんですね
永遠な命というものが
この宗教を信仰すればあなたは永遠になりますと
この約束のちょっと違うところは死んでからなんです
だからすごくうまく逃げられるんです
宗教は だから宗教は無事にいまだに世の中にあるんです
約束破っちゃったら そのシステムが壊れるでしょ
宗教は約束破ってないんだと誰にも言えないんです
会社であろうが普通の人間だったら
約束破ったら まあそれでも人間関係終わっちゃうんですね
宗教だけはよく元気でいるもんですよ
なぜかと約束はもう後の約束
死んでからの約束だから誰にも言えないんですよ
例えば僕が言ったら あなたの宗教を信じていますけど
まだまだ永遠にはなってないんだと
いい加減にしなさい あんたまだ生きてるで
死んでからでしょう 天国に行くのはと言われたらもう何も言うことはないんです
ですから もう元気でいますけど
宗教は それにも仏教はなんかちょっとケチをつけてるんですね
死んでからの約束はまあちょっと不満ですと
そこで例えば中国的な文化を考えちゃうと
この不老長寿ですか そういう概念があるんですね
いろんなことをすれば
まあ年取らないと長寿はできますと
不死になるんだと 仙人になるんだとかね
やっぱり人間がそういう道を探し求めているんですね
で そこでおかしいところは
人間がこの体を長寿にしてあげたいんですね
この体で死にたくないとかね
いろいろ問題があって
お釈迦様はなんとか解決を探さなくちゃいけないと
そこで解決を見つかって教えたのが仏教なんです
そこで他の宗教と違って
このご利益教ではないんです
現代人というのは この社会の失敗作だから宗教に入っちゃうでしょ
宗教に入ってご利益を欲しがっちゃうんですね
商売繁盛とか健康とか家庭円満とか
なんとか宗教から求めちゃがっちゃうんですね
お経をあげたり 呪文を唱えたり
百八十八か所回ったり
いろいろことをして 何か精神的なトラブルを起こしちゃったら
順序にして それでこのご利益をほしがっちゃうんですね
で そこはちょっと問題なんですね
お釈迦様で則則がありまして
そのご利益は教えないんです
それちょっと甘い話なんです
例えば夫婦は喧嘩しているんだと
そこでお子さんがもう喧嘩生活は良くないんだと
何か悪い例でも憑いてるんではないかと思って
何かどこかに行って祈祷師にあって
いろいろ祈祷してもらったりすると
ということは 仏教はちょっと考えてくださいと言うんです
お釈迦様に聞いたならば
同じ質問聞いたんです
喧嘩するのはもう生の夫婦だから
あなた方二人が何とかしなさいと
家庭円満のために でお釈迦様は家庭円満の話があるんです
どうやって家庭円満になりますかと
そこでこういうこういうおさなえしなさいとか全くないんです
このお経は八十四万回あげなさいとかね
このお守りを持ってぶらくり首にぶら下がっちゃったら
あなたの家庭は円満になります
全くなし きれいさっぱり全くなし
で 夫婦が来たら旦那に言うのは
うちの権時を奥さんに任せなさいと
自分の財産は全部奥さんに任せなさいと
うちの主人が自分の奥さんであると
男はいくら偉くたっても
家に入ったらうちで偉いのは自分の奥さんであると
そこでちゃんと仕事を褒めなさいと
奥さん一生懸命やってるんだから
みんな当たり前だと男たち思ってるでしょ
当たり前じゃないんで
それなりに大変だからね
それちゃんと褒めなくちゃいけないんです
男が会社で褒めてもらってるでしょうに
いい仕事をしたら収入増えちゃうでしょ
それも褒め ご褒美でしょうし
あるいは上司に褒められるし
社会に認められるし 奥さんのことは？誰も褒めてあげないんですね
評価しないんですね ですから
それは旦那の仕事でちゃんと褒めなさいと
それから装飾品ですか
アクセサリーとかプレゼントとかね
ちゃんと持って行きなさいと
それからちゃんと 何て言いますか
尊敬 敬意 尊敬しなさいと
その５つ守ればもう OK と
どれほど合理的で具体的かと
お経をあげなさいとかね
大目付 8万4000回唱えなさいとかね
それ逃げなんですよ お互いに喧嘩するんだったら
どこかで逃げて ちょっといい顔して変わったら一日ぐらいうまくいくかもしれませんよ
他のところで気持ちよくなったんだから我慢できる
一日ぐらいは で ２日目からまた我慢できないでしょうに
だから問題はあるところで解決しろと
同じく奥さんにもお釈迦様はおっしゃってるんです
家の財産は自分のものでないんだから
盗んだりしないで 男を煽てなさいと
ちゃんとおだてて なぜならば
特に立場がなくなっちゃったら仕事できなくなっちゃいますからね
ですから それなりに男の人を褒めておだてて生活しなさいと
それから家のしきたり習慣ありますね
どうせ女の人っていうのは大変悲しいことに全く関係ないうちに行かなくちゃいけないんですね
それすごい大変なことなんです
みんなお嫁に行きたがっちゃいますけど
それどれほど人の家に入ってて大変かと
お嫁に行く前に考えないんですね
行ってからもう姑さんが悪いとかね
あの家のこの性格は気に入らないとか文句言っちゃうんだけど
もう遅いんです 行く前に考えなくちゃいけないんです
とにかくその苦しみは
女性がこの社会では味わわなくちゃいけない
こうやってるんですね
向こうにいる場合は違いますけどね
婿入りする場合は男は同じ大変さ味わっちゃうんです
どっちでも同じことでしょうに
お嫁に行ったって 婿にしたってもね
大変ということ誰かに
そこでお奥さんにお釈迦様が言うのは
この家のしきたり ちゃんとその通りに守りなさいと
それから旦那の親戚があるんですね
その親戚に対してすごく礼を持ってちゃんとやりなさい
そうでなきゃ危ないんです
それだけ守ると素晴らしい奥さんだとみんな褒めちゃうんです
問題ないんです ですから
そういう風な教えなんです
仏教というのは この超能力やら人相力の話やら
この神秘的な話やら持ってこないんです
問題は問題が生まれたところで
客観的に具体的に見てみなさいと
どこに生まれたかと 会社の将来うまくいかないと
あっちこっちもう修行したってもうまくいかないかもしれません
修行したってもいいんだけど
例えば新しい考え方出てこないし
混乱ばっかりで これダメだからとちょっと落ち着きましょうと
ということで修行するのはそれでいいんだけど
修行の徳によって 不可思議な力によって会社がうまくいくんだなと思ったら
それはちょっと甘いんです
そうじゃなくて 修行してしっかりしてるんだと
頭はもう冴えてきましたと
じゃあ頑張るぞと というふうに頑張ってほしいんです
ですから この生老病死の問題でも
お釈迦様は何か不老長寿の薬を発見しましたとか
人は死なないように何か工夫を発見したとかね
そういう人間の欲望に応えているわけじゃなく
それは徹底的に問題があるところで分析しちゃったんですね
問題はどこにありますかというと
人はどうせ生まれる どうせ年取る
どうせ病気になる どうせ死ぬんです
これ覚悟すれば別にどうったことないんです
問題はそれ嫌と思う心にあるんですよ
別に病気になったんだからって不幸でもなんでもないでしょうに
病気になったらちょっと不自由になるだけで
薬あれば薬するか 治療法あれば治療法する
不治の病だったらまあ死ぬまで待つ
それだけのことでしょうに
不治の病だったら あと２年で死にますよと思っちゃったら
ちゃんともうね 日にちはわかってるんだから
そこでどうしますかとかね
みんなともう仲良くして
今まで喧嘩した人々を呼んで
呼び 呼んで 申し訳ないんですがとね
まあもう仲良くしましょうと
もう短いんだから 先がとかね
で 孫たちがいるんだったら
思い存分孫たちと遊んだりとかね
そういうふうに充実した生活ができるのに
問題は あー死にたくないと
何か治療法ないんだと
不治の病だったら不治の病だからね
治療あるんだったらお医者さんはやってくれるしね
そこでがんになったら胃も取って体も半分取ってでも生きてきたがっちゃうんですね
体の半分取っちゃったらもう人間ではないし
あっちこっち管ばっかしで機械で生かされてて
あれ地獄の苦しみ味わっちゃうんですね
だからこれ何て言いますか
あの ことわざがないんですか
日本では そういう一回ひどい目にあっただけじゃなくて
また二度目にひどい目に遭うというふうなことなんですね
自分の国にはちょっとした言葉があるんです
木から落ちた人に 人が牛に牛に襲われたんだと
木から落ちて骨が折って大変ですけど
もう牛も来てまた ということわざがあるんです
日本でも確実にそのようなことわざあると思いますけどね
まあ今思い出せない 僕は勉強していないんだから思い出せないのは当たり前ですけど
皆さんも知ってるだろうと思いますけどね
うん ありますか そうそうそうそう
そんなような まあそれちょっと力強くないんだけど
そのことわざはね もうちょっとインパクトのある
まあ探せばあります まあそれで結構ですけど
とにかく であの とにかく我々はね
もうがんになって死にかけてるのに
あっちこっち切って切って切って切って
もうさらに苦しむ その苦しみはどこから生まれてくるんですかというと
これは嫌だと思うんだからなんです
この人生はそんなものだと納得していないんですね
わかりやすく言えば 人間っていうのは完全なバカなんです
年取るのをやめられますかね
どうやってやめられますか？細胞の動きをやめちゃったら人が死んじゃうでしょうに
細胞は毎日毎日変化しなきゃ生きていないでしょうに
そんなものやめられません
それは魚に例えると 水に魚が原形でいるんだけど
水が嫌いだというならば死んでしまうしか方法ないんです
誰かの餌でも食べちゃって
僕はこの釣り 釣りで釣ってる魚は食べるなと冗談で言ってるんですけど
バカだからあの魚が 簡単に食べようと思って
釣られちゃいますよ 人間も同じくね
簡単にしようと思っちゃったらすぐ釣られます
まあですからこの問題はこの我々の屁理屈なところに無知なところにあるんです
だから仏教と呼んで智慧の教えと
智慧が現れたら全く違う人生論が生まれてくるはずなんです
全く違う哲学が全く違う生き方が何のことなくすごい楽な生き方が現れてくるんです
死ぬ前に ですから 死ぬ前に最高たる幸福をつかまれるんです
ですから この問題は生老病死の運命で生まれて
それが嫌だ それは嫌だと
魚だったら水の中にいなさい
文句を言うなと で 水が嫌だったらカエルにカエルぐらいに進化しなきゃ
もう陸上に上げます 上げられません
いけませんし それ大変なことですからね
ですから お釈迦様はこういう真理を喋っている
全ては無常であると 私の人生だけじゃないんです
全て一切は無常であると
それをパーリ語でアニッチャというんです
いわゆる全てのものは変化しているんです
停止してないんです 全て私だけじゃない
他の人間だけじゃない
他の動物だけじゃない
この地球だけじゃない
この宇宙さえも変化しているんです
そこだけじゃない 我々精神というものが
心というものは それまた瞬間瞬間変化しているでしょうに
体より早く心が変化するでしょう
今泣いて今笑っちゃいますからね
喧嘩してすぐまた仲直りしちゃいますから
心の変化というのは体をより激しく変化するんです
ですから 我々の精神さえ無常であると
そこをお釈迦様はこの人間に幸福にしてあげる方法はないかなと探したところで発見したのはそれなんです
何か永遠不滅の天国ではないんです
そんなものはないということを発見したんです
ものは停止しちゃったらそこに行くこともできないでしょう
たとえ永遠の天国があったとしても
一人も行けないんです
そこは永遠だから変化しないんだから
新しい人が入っちゃったら
それ変化してるでしょ
例えば永遠の天国ある
そこに 1万人の住民がいると
そこで私は行きませんだけど
皆様の誰かが亡くなって
その永遠に天国に行こうとする
そこで 1万1人の住民になるでしょうね
そうすると永遠の天国の状態変わっちゃうでしょ
だから永遠じゃなくなっちゃうんです
ですから どういうふうに合理的に考えたても
永遠という状態っていうのは存在しない
成り立たない 全ては変化する
ですから 仏教では他宗教を批判しません
でも間接的に何か間接的にちょっと言ってるんです
だからこの永遠になりたいという頑張る連中がまあバカではないかということはないんだから
そんなものは それは言わない
失礼だから その代わりに徹底的に無常論を喋る
それはすごい科学的に合理的に話してやる
瞬間でも何かありますかと
電気を見てください すーっと光子という分子が流れているでしょうに
そうでなければ光はない
電子がすーっと流れて消えて流れて消えているんだから
ここに蛍光灯があって光があるんです
私の音でも体のエネルギーはすっと音として流れていって
それ皆様の体に入ってるんだから
その無常の波がなければ音は存在しない
蛍光灯も存在しない だから存在っていうのは無常そのものなんです
そこでまた人間の頭の悪いところまた出てくるんです
どういうことかというと
仏教は暗いんだと 無常無常だと呼んだと
他の宗教だったら本当に極楽堂の話やら天国の話やら幸福の話やら
楽しいんじゃないかと
仏教は暗いんだと それで仏教は一発言うんです
無常でなければ あなたは今の瞬間も生きてないんだと
どうやって生きてるんですか？無常でなければ
呼吸できますか？今ずっと私はこの部屋の中にある酸素を体に入れて
体にあった二酸化炭素を出してるでしょう
今 今もう一時間 まあもうそろそろ時間になってくるんだけど
あれだけは私の体の一部がこの部屋にあったものにもなり入れ替えてるんです
それ生きてるんだからなんです
だからもう入った私が今いませんでしょ
物質は変わってるんだから
それで しゃべるたびに私の体に入っていたエネルギーが外へ出たでしょうに
ですから 僕は質的にも量的にも違うものなんです
この塊が今は もし私は質的に量的に変化しませんでいたら
もう生きてないんです
だから無常は苦というというと
これ我慢できないんですよ
あまりにも馬鹿馬鹿らしいんです
蛍光灯はいないんだから
無常でなければ花は咲きませんだから
木は実りませんだから
この世の中で音楽というものはないんだから
無常でなければ 例えば皆様方
自分のまあもうお互いの子どもたちやら夫婦やら
お互いに会ったり話したりして楽しいでしょうに
自分の子供を見触れて気持ちよくなるでしょうに
それ無常だからなんです
子供は体に触れたっても
皮膚が全く永遠で変化しませんのでいたっても触れたって分からないでしょうし
ここでここは子供は楽しく頑張っていると
こちら側の心が変化しちゃうでしょ
こっちでも楽しくなる
子供が悲しがっていると
こちらも心配になっちゃう
こちらの心も変化する
それは生きていることだから
それ事実だから ですから
仏教は無常を教えているんだから苦いやという知識人ぶり知識人かぶりですね
あれは ああいうふうに偉そうなことを言う人は
全くもう本は読んでいるかもしれませんだけど
もう馬鹿には変わりがないんです
ちゃんと見ると無常こそ人生であって
無常こそ存在であって
そこまでいかなくたっても
物理学を勉強してみればどうですかね
ずっとそれを通してもう我々変化しているでしょうに
そこで私はこうやって立ってるんだけど
私の体は穴だらけで ありとあらゆる今電波障害でしょ
この国は みんな携帯電話持ってるんだから
あっちこっちからありとあらゆる電波が体通って体通って行ってるんではないか
だから電波から見れば穴だらけだから
こっち通っていこうかなとかね
そこで太陽から膨大な量のニュートリノという素粒子が流れているでしょうに
そういうものは体通って地球通って出て行っちゃうでしょうに
体体に太陽の光を与えて
それエネルギーでしょ
重いものなんです 体に入っちゃうと体が重くなるんです
ですから 物理学的に見ても
無常だから生きているんです
我々に物事を考えますか
考えられますかね 神経から信号を行ったり
脳でいろいろおかしい反応を起こさない限りは
ですから 無常は決して暗い話じゃないんです
暗い話というと 僕らはきつく答えるんです
なぜならば これは大事な哲学だと真理だから
[背景笑い]そんなもうもうあり得もない嘘をついて人を騙すことは良くないんです
非合理的な永遠というパーマネントというエターナルという仏教はものすごくこのエターニティエターナルという言葉に反対するんです
英語ではエターニティというんです
で これはパーリ語でまた言葉ありますけどね
サッサと そこでこのヒンドゥー教という宗教がございます
で そのヒンドゥー教では高度なヒンドゥー教ではこう言うんです
初めは真理があったんだと
それは神であって 神話であって
ブラフマンであって 名前はどうでもいいんですと
真理というものは一体唯一のものがあって
それは二分化する 二分化して現象の社会が現れ始める
二分化したら ところで
二つに割れたものがどんどん変化して
宇宙ができてきて 現象ができてきて
宇宙が地球ができてきて
人間ができてきてとか
そういうふうに喋るんです
なんか賢そうに聞こえるんです
進化論にも似てるんじゃないかと
それで我々は人間になったんだから
現象の世界になったんだから苦しんでいるだけですよと
本当は真理そのものですよと
それをアドヴェーと言うんです
ノンデュアリティ これフ・ニと言うんです
日本語で一つだ ものは一つですよ
フ・ニ二つに分らすという
それはヒンドゥー哲学では最高のレベルの哲学なんです
アドヴェーヴェーダントと言うんです
ヴェーダの最後 シャンカラという哲学者が作った教えなんです
そこで そういう方々は本当に頭は良かったかもしれませんだけど
我々に言ってるのは 我々は幻覚の中にいるんだと
ただ分かってないだけだと
本当は真理そのものだと
だからヨーガでもやって
悟りでも開けば真理と一緒になるんだと
神が一如になるんだと
そうすると永遠ではないかと
そういうふうに言うと
なんかみんななるほど分かったような気がしましょうと
合理的だからといって
あれすごい落とし穴があるんですよ
そこまでいいんだけど
私が聞きたいのは もともと一体であったあの真理そのものが
なんで二分化したんですかと
もし我々は修行して悟ってヨーガやってそこに行っても
あいつは信頼できないんだから
また二分化しちゃったらどうするんですかね
またこっち戻っちゃいますから
だからそこにもやっぱり論理的にちょっとした過ちがあるんです
まあ普通なら立派な教えで
みんな一生懸命修行する
そういうのは別に問題ないんです
みんなヨーガをやったり
大変いろいろ心清らかにする行をやっちゃうし
それなりに結果もあるし
瞑想すればやっぱり仏教だけではなくて
ヒンドゥー教で瞑想したっても心は良くなりますよ
それは問題ないんです
僕は問題にするのはこの真理のポイントなんです
そこで そのもしその教えが正しければ
その真理 元々のあった真理自体さえも無常なんです
二分化できるんだから
ですから 無常論はには乗り越えられないんです
そういうことで ああいう風の教えはもうお釈迦様否定してないんで
その代わりにまあもうちょっとだと
もうちょっとだと なぜなら真面目に修行している立派なね
別にもう教えはあれですけど
人間としては立派に生活していて
リベラルな人々だから
まあそんなに悪口言う必要はないし
ですからもうちょっとですよと
あんた方の考え方は ですから
このやっぱり無常しかもう言うことがない
ですから全ては無常である
そうすると神様がいても
仏教の人々にとっては別に問題ないんです
だから仏教は他の宗教にももう平気で行っちゃうんです
日本ではよく見えることで
どんな宗教でも行くでしょ
大体 misu 4つぐらい宗教持ってますからね
ヨーロッパ人にとってはそれすごくわからないんですね
何でお寺に見て神社に行くんですかと
まあ日本人にとっては別にどうったことないんです
結婚式は教会でやって
昇進はお寺でやって 子供生まれたら神社に行くと
ご利益さえ得ればどこでもいいと
あんまりそこら辺はおおらかで
もう僕でも大体そんなもんだと思っちゃいますよ
別にそこにそういう点では悪口言いたくないんです
何かに凝り固まってないのはいいんじゃないかと
僕でもたまに友達に頼まれて昔は教会なんかに行ったんだけど
その時はもう今はこういう風にしますと言ったら
はい 分かります それ言われる通りにするんです
別にだからといって私が何かなるわけでもないし
別にもう人のしきたりに従ったってもね
それは問題ないんです
そこで 例えばもしキリスト教の神様がいるならば
いるかもしれません でも
その人もそんなにすごい力持ちじゃなくて
やっぱり力持ってるだけですから
自分に力持ってるぐらいは人の面倒を見るかもしれません
ですから 地球上の人類をみんな救ってあげることは神様にできない
聖書から見たってもちゃんとわかるでしょ
我々は頑張らなきゃ救えませんだから
神様に一人でできません
ちゃんとしたキリスト教だったら
我々は神を信仰して洗礼を受けて
残業をして罪を赦してもらって
もうイエス様のね あの女なんですか
その売春腹賠償というんですか
それを自分で払わなくたっても
イエス様がなさったんだから
それでお願いしますと
そのチケットでイエス様のチケットで天国に行かなくちゃいけない
チケットないと天国に入れないんですね
もし神様が偉大な力を持っているならば
みんな来てくださいと言うでしょうに
だからやっぱり事実 その教えの中でも見えるんですよ
見ると あ なるほど 私たちは頑張らなくちゃいけないんだと
ということは 神様は絶対的じゃないんだと見えるはずなんです
だからとことんキリスト教で道徳を押しちゃってますよ
人を愛しなさいと 夜酌しなさいと
欲を欲張るなと 嘘を言うなと
浮気するどころか 他人の女の人でこんなちらっとも見るなと
それぐらい道徳を喋ってるんで
だから道徳喋ってるところはもう問題ないんです
それはまさにその通りで
守れば幸福になります
キリスト教でおっしゃっているように
道徳を守れば確実に幸福になります
それは問題ないんです
問題はこの論理ですか
そこにあるんです 永遠ではない
神様も生きているんです
だから無常なんです しょうがないんです
真理だから無常でないと生きていることはないんです
そういうことで お釈迦様は徹底的に無常という哲学を
真理を発見して あ なるほど
人間これわかってないんだと
だから苦しんでるんだと
もう一つ言葉があるんです
なぜ無常かということ
無常だと言ったら分かりますけど
なぜ無常かという そこはこの物事に現象は不完全なんですね
不完全だから完全になろうとするんです
して壊れちゃうんです
川っていうのは流れるでしょ
流れなきゃ川じゃなくて湖だからね
なぜ川が流れるんですか？安定していないんですね
[背景音楽]で なんでここに光ありますか？ここで光通して電気のエネルギーを消しちゃうでしょ
終わる と電線に入っているエネルギーとこちらではこの
何て言いますか あれは
この 言葉あるんですね
力の差が生まれてくるんですね
そこで電気は蛍光灯の中に流れていっちゃうんですね
だから蛍光灯の方が光として出ていっちゃいますから
この出ていったものは他のところから得たがっちゃうし
そこでそうやって電気が流れるんですね
全てはそういうもので
我々の体も同じく食べた
昼ご飯食べたんだけど
まあそれはそれなりに出て行っちゃうと不安定な状態になっちゃう
そうするとまた食べる
止まって止まってるならばもう食べなくてもいいんです
朝食べたご飯 そのまんまでお腹の中にあるならば
もう二度と食べなくてもいいんです
でも エネルギーにするために食べたんだから
それはそれなりに変化しちゃうんですね
お腹にご飯入った瞬間で胃がもうもう嫌なんですね
なんか変なもの入っちゃう
そこで胃がもういろいろ胃酸出したり
いろいろなことをして
それはもう溶かしたりするんですね
溶かしてもう出してやるんですね
そういうふうなことなんです
ですから この不安定な状態
まあ電子の話ではポテンシャルディファレンスですか
それで物事はできているんです
なんでモーター回りますかというと
不安定だからなんです
エネルギーの割れ差なんですね
だから回しちゃうんです
だから無常でも無常でもあると同時に不安定でもある
不安定であるんだから流れる
その 2種類の不安定があるんです
物質には不安定 精神的なところには不満
我々は心から見ればいつでも不満なんですね
だから働きますよ 音楽を聴く
楽しくなっちゃったんだけど
なんかちょっと不安 そうすると CD 買っちゃう
また聞こうと 音楽一つ聴いただけで満足しましたと思ったら
もう CD は買わないんです
音楽聴いたところでまた聴きたいと
なんでまた聴きたがるの？今聴いて足らないんだからなんです
そこで CD 買っちゃうんです
ですから 精神的に言えば不満
物質的に言えば不安 不安定
その心理 2つがあるんです
だから無常なんです 変化するんです
お金が足らないと不満があった人は仕事をして金儲かりますから
自分の美しさ足らないなと不安がある方は一生懸命美しくしようと努力する
ですから 人間が動くのは不満だから動いているんです
物質動いているのは不安定だから動いているんです
それには仏教ではドゥッカと呼ぶんです
その状態は この言葉で覚えてください
これ大変難しい 大変高度な考え方なんです
行動は行動だけど すぐわかりやすいでしょうに
不安定と不満というのは
そんな大したことないんです
なんでその言葉で覚えてくださいと言うと
これはまあ苦と訳するんですね
日本語だったら苦しみという感じで
まあそれ別にまあそれでもいいんだけど
それぐらいの苦しいやという意味だけではないんです
ですから お釈迦様は一切は苦であると
一切皆苦と言うんです
だから仏教は暗い また同じ問題が出てくるんですよ
それは全ては苦しい 苦しいと言っているのは
そんなレベルの低い話じゃないんです
全てはもう不安と不安
不満と不安定で流れていくんだと
そこで次に出てくるなぜそうなるかという
また なぜ不安 不安定かというと
安定というようなものがないことで
実体がない 例えば川っていうのは流れないようにすると湖になっちゃう
そこで湖が止まっちゃうんですね
そういう風になっちゃったら
川にはならなくなっちゃうんですね
で 電気にもじゃあここで止まろうというところはなし
行く行くところ自分が変化しなくちゃいけないし
だから全ては現象だけであって
実体はない 変化しない実体はないと
そこは仏教では無我と言うんです
アナッタと 我に争うというのは無我ですね
我は私という何かないんだと
で 今私たちは私がいると思ってるでしょ
あれはもう単なる考え方だけなんです
私はいません なんか皆様方は人間というのは大変理屈そうに
知識人そうに私がいると思ってますけど
どこら辺私ですかね 全部分解してみると
私ではなくて私のとなっちゃうんです
私は逃げるんです 例えば私を発見しようと
私がこの体の中にいるんだから
外に発見する必要ないんです
私が他のところにいるわけじゃないんだから
ここに実際にいるんだから
ですから ここを見ると
これは私ですかと 手を見て
いえ これは私の手 目は？それは私の目と
髪の毛は？それ私の髪の毛
心臓は？それ私の心臓
心臓 じゃあ脳みそは？それは私の脳みそと
じゃあ私はどこにいるんですか？ないでしょうに
全部私のと よく逃げるんですよ
この私という じゃあ考え方は私ですか？違います
それは私の考え方 じゃあ感覚は？いえ
それ私の感覚 どこにいるんですかね
そうすると どこにもいない
それの人間というのは
この言葉に騙されちゃうんです
私は行きます 私は座ります
私は寝ますと 私は怒りますとか
これ言語では私はということなんです
それはただの言葉の問題なんです
理解するときは言葉で理解するんです
そこをちょっと間違っちゃって
私がいると思っちゃいます
そこはすごい無明であって誤解なんです
ですから 仏教で無我ということを言ってるんです
探せばないよと 証拠を出してみなさいと
あるならばと だいたい一般的な世界ではよく言うんです
私の魂がありますではないか
人が死んでも魂は死にませんではないかと
じゃあ見た人がいるんですかね
この死なない魂が なぜならば体が死ぬことは知ってますけど
体より頑固な燃やしても燃えない
切っても切れない 焼いても焼けない
頑固な霊魂魂があるならば
手より足より髪の毛より見えるはずでしょう
体験できるでしょうに
体験できないでしょ あれはただの言葉で我々を騙されてるだけ
ですから 実体がないと
だから無我と そういうふうな真理をお釈迦様はどんどん発見したんです
ですから真理はそれしかないんです
それで人間はどうなるかと
二つになります 一つは大ショックを受ける
頭狂っちゃう それ聞くと
まず 僕も大体気をつけて喋ったんだけど
本当に力入れて喋ってたらみんな頭おかしくなると思います
僕はおかしくならないようにいろいろ情報言いながら
もういくらか納得してもらいながら喋りましたけど
ドーンと言っちゃって頭狂っちゃうんです
ある日お釈迦様が言ったんです
お釈迦様にこの実体のことを話してね
人が聞いて お釈迦様の弟子でしたけど
結局はね 出家して まあいろいろややこしい質問するんですね
そこでまあしょうがなく説明したんです
それでその人大ショック受けちゃったんです
受けたらお釈迦様アーナンダ尊者にね
愚か者はね 無我と聞いたらもう頭狂っちゃいますよと
余計な角度で余計な質問するんだからと
ですから お釈迦様おっしゃる通りに丁寧に聞いた方が頭が狂わない
ですから 皆様の頭も大丈夫なんです
僕はまあ お釈迦様がおっしゃった通りに
大変丁寧に順番でのんびりと言っていましたから
で なんで頭が狂っちゃいますかというと
我々いまだに私がいるんだ
尊い私がいるんだ 私は死んだから死んでから成仏するんだ
極楽堂に行くんだ 楽しくなるんだ
天国に行くんだ 天使になるんだとかね
それいっぱい希望あるでしょうに
普通だったら 何にもないんだって言われちゃったら狂っちゃうんじゃないでしょうか
自分の希望は全部なくなっちゃいますから
ですから ちゃんと丁寧に人の能力をね
育てながら喋らなくちゃいけない話なんです
そういうことで 一つはこういう話を聞くと
みんな大ショックを受けて頭は狂っちゃうということがあるんです
もう一つは ああ なんだ
もう何も今まで一生懸命馬鹿みたく執着して
あれやらなくちゃ これやらなくちゃとか頑張ったし
死んでからも何とかしなくちゃ
お墓がどうするんですか？とかね
成仏したらどうするんですか？とか
もう死んでも体でも自分が計画立てたり
もう大変苦労していたんだけど
ああ リラックスすればいいんだと
全ては捨てればいいんだと
希望を全て捨てて大きな心でいれば
それこそ道だという最高の幸福を味わうか狂うかどっちかなんです
ですから まあそういうふうなお釈迦様はそういう真理を見つかったんです
そこで人間の問題はこの死にたくないという問題
それは分かりますよ 死にたくないという気持ちは
なぜならば生きていても不満なんです
物足らない もっと生きていきたい
家族とずっと一緒にいたのに
もっといたいんです 物足らないんです
この不満から欲が生まれるんです
欲が生まれるんだから
皆様悪いわけじゃないんです
カツアゲやるんだ 煩悩あるんだから
だから汚れてる連中だ
悪いんだってそんなことないんです
これしょうがないんです
欲 煩悩あるのは なしならばご飯食べたって満足することはないんだから
最高なご飯食べたわけじゃないんだから
ご飯自体が無常だから
もっと食べたくなるんです
男の人は綺麗な女の人に出会って
ああ この人と一生やりますよと思って結婚してやっても
やっぱり自分結婚した相手は最高たる理想的な人じゃないんだから
あっちこっち見るとまた違う違う形の人が見えちゃうんです
そちらもちょっと目がいっちゃうんです
それはやっぱり不完全だから出てくるものなんです
ですから 我々は煩悩あって汚い連中ではなくて
被害者なんです 存在の
無常たる存在の被害者なんです
皆様が怒るならば 皆様が悪いというよりは被害者なんです
気に入らない現象が起こった
それまた当たり前なんです
気に入らないものには怒りで反応する
気に入っているものが起こりました
それに欲ができる 出てくる
だから現象のもう操り人形になっちゃって
もう生きてるんじゃなくて生かされてるという日本語の言葉あるでしょ
生かされてるんですね
だから被害者なんです
生かされてるってことは
日本語ではありがたい話でとってますけど
僕は全くありがたくない話でとってるんです
生かされてるのが何にもありがたくないでしょうと
生かされてるということは
桜の花が咲くともうもう感情が湧いてくる
バカバカらしいでしょうに
何のことなくもう１週間で散る桜にこちらの心まで支配することできるんだから
恥ずかしくないんですかね
夜真夜中犬でも吠えちゃったら
暴走族でもなんかね まあ音を出して走っちゃったら夜寝られなくてイライラするんだと
ちょっとした外音に自分を支配されちゃいますから
なんだこの心はと ありがたいんですかね
だから生かされていることは確実に生かされているんだけど
もう可哀想なんですね
奴隷なんですね 操られているんですね
そういうことで我々に煩悩が生まれるのはもう当たり前でどうしようもない
無常だから生まれるんです
子供が生まれたらものすごく喜びますけど
子供は人間だから不完全なんですよ
そこでいろいろ生まれてきますよ
何やらあだこでもっと勉強すればいいのにとかね
と言ったって子供はもう不完全だから自分にできるだけのことをやっていますよ
でもこちらでは納得いかないし
そこで煩悩が生まれてくる
そこで子供に怒る それで子供もそれに反応する
それでもっとひどい目になってしまっちゃうんです
親子関係まで崩れてしまって
最終的に ですから 我々には道が二つしかない
一つはそのシステムを理解する
もう一つは操れないようにする
いわゆる欲を捨てる すべての欲を捨てる
いくら欲あったっても満たされません
一つやっと満たしてくれると次の問題が出てくる
それはもう確実にそうなるんです
ですから 存在に執着するんじゃなくて
存在そのものはもうポイとゴミ箱に捨てる
生きていきたいという気持ちを捨てること
生きた 生きたがるんじゃなくて
死にたくないんじゃなくて
死にたくなくなる気持ちを捨てること
放っておけと 全ては捨てるんだから
結局 嫌で嫌をなしに だから覚悟を決める
覚悟をすると それは悟りというすっごい高いレベルの智慧なんです
それすごい具体的なんです
大雑把なものじゃないんです
すごく楽なんです 例えば自分が財布を持っていて
まあ高いいっぱいお金詰んで
詰まって もう何か買い物でもしようと
ったところで 買い物しようところで財布はないと
どこかで落ちちゃって
みんな代償を受けるでしょ
もしその人が悟ってたならば 「
ああそう ないか はい分かった」と
なぜならばあり得ることだから
別に そんなことは 財布もなくなって
その上またもう大パニック来て
また倍二倍損する必要ないでしょ
蹴っ蹴ったり踏んだりだから
それはなし ですから有名な例えがあります
我々日本語でも使う例えなんですね
第１番目の矢には刺されますけど
第２番目の矢にはブッダは刺されませんと
第1番目の矢っていうのは
我々と同じく年は取るは病気になるは損はするは
いろいろ我々生きてるんだから
もう問題には出会う だからといって悩むことはなしと
一般の人は二倍悩む 損もして
その上悩んだりもする
倍以上悩む 悟った人は
例えばもう電車に乗ると足が滑っちゃったら怪我すると
ああ怪我しました 痛いやと
それで終わっちゃうんです
普通の人は何でこうなっちゃうんですか？とかね
ああだこうだとか いろいろ文句まで言ったりして
私の運が悪いんじゃないかとかね
いろいろ考えたりするでしょ
どんどん悩みが続けていっちゃうんです
だからもう時間になりましたけど
言えるのは怖がるなと
不幸に どうなることや無常だからわからないでしょうに
いつ死ぬかわからないでしょうに
家は火事になるか もう子供は事故を起こして死ぬか
自分が死ぬか どう何かもこの世の中何さっぱりわからない
あと一時間で大地震起きて全部無茶苦茶になるかわからない
東京のことをもう想像してください
大地震起きちゃったら
こんな大勢の人々はどうするんですかと
ですからいいんじゃないですか
そんなことは その時は
その時は生きていればそれでありがたいし
死んじゃったらそれでそれでありがたいしと
生きていれば ああ こんなひどい目に遭ったのに
私は生きてるんだからいいんじゃないかと
死んじゃったら ああ 死んで苦労なしでよかったということなんですよ
ですから この不幸に怖がるなと
幸福だけ欲しい欲しいと
そんな屁理屈を望むな
望まないこと 世の中っていうのは幸福があって不幸がある
損があって得がある 褒められてあって貶される
そういうふうに流れていくんです
それに冷静な心でいること
そういう強い心を悟り通して修行によって作るということを
お釈迦様の真理の世界
また四分の一しか言えなかったんだけど
またいろいろありますけど
まあそこら辺に終了いたします